hi everyone welcome to today's webinar
the state of the observability and log
management in 2022.
we're currently in the midst of a
perfect storm of massive data growth and
a need for innovation
in order to shed light on key trends
observability challenges and some of the
approaches to resolving those
observability challenges we went ahead
and surveyed over 315 it professionals
across a variety of industries
in this survey we got their perspectives
on the current state of exploding data
and their struggle to gather valuable
insights from that data
our goal in running the survey was one
to understand what's driving the massive
growth of observability data and two
what approaches will help teams be more
productive
today we're excited to share the results
of the survey and some of the data
points that help us answer those
questions
i'm richard gibson i work on the
marketing team here at era software has
a few items i'd like to address before
we dive in
first we'll be sharing the full
presentation after the webinar so no
need to worry about taking notes or
screenshots
second there will be some attachments
you could open and download during our
presentation
and finally if there's any questions
that come to mind during the
presentation go ahead and submit them
and we'll save some time at the end to
answer those questions
before we get into the webinar i'd like
to introduce you to our two speakers
first up we have todd person who is the
co-founder and ceo of era software and
presenting with him is stella udobicic
who is the senior vice president of
marketing at era software
stella the floor is all yours
thank you very much uh richard um it is
my pleasure to share a very exclusive
findings from our first ever state of
observability and log management reports
with you as richard mentioned here's
some of our goals uh the primary
research goal was to capture a very hard
data on trends observability and log
management trends and understand
um what's happening in the market going
forward in 2022 and beyond we run this
survey in february 2022 and
as richard mentioned we surveyed
more than 300 professionals both
executives and individual contributors
and all professionals had responsibility
for managing availability
and cloud environments application and
infrastructures
so here's some of our
graphics
[Music]
we divided uh demographic english volume
of data and industry we gather data from
across the spectrum and industries from
fintech technology transportation energy
etc and also we targeted customers
enterprises and organizations that have
at least 10 terabyte of log data to
manage
and when it comes to different role
levels we had almost a third of
distribution of i.t executives a third
of devops and sre practitioners and also
uh cloud and application and enterprise
architects consisted for about 34
regionally this survey focused on north
america with about 75 percent of people
coming from united states in canada uh
some in europe about fifth um and a
little bit in asia pacific
so there are three big uh groups of
trends that emerged when we ran our
survey the first group it is that
overall there is a huge volume in growth
in observability data
so the first question that we have asked
is how does your it organization deal
with all that data
majority of users and what are the uses
that organizations have and majority of
users are in troubleshooting and
monitoring the performance of
applications and infrastructures
improving security and also supporting
uh ift audits
there is one very interesting finding
that we have captured and this also that
log data is still very heavily used for
understanding not only user experience
but both user and product experience
and that's very very interesting despite
some of them like over the years um
investments made in more specialized
tooling such as application performance
monitoring and one of the reasons that
could be the case
because apm tools are seen as very very
expensive so people still resort to uh
use logs uh to understand user
experience
so
we expected that i t has variety of
users from log data but we were also
pleasantly surprised to see that
insights from understanding from
analyzing log data is seen across the
organizations and also
within the uh within the business and
lives of business stakeholders for a
variety of use cases
one is understanding
customer activities um compliance
reporting is big and also as i mentioned
improving product and user experience
one anecdotal finding is that um
less than one percent also commented
that they use essays to predict
failures so that's interesting to find
well i kind of expected to see more of
using
using logs and applying ai and ml
techniques on top to predict failures
and this is certainly something that
we'll expect to see in the future due to
massive amount of log data we're going
to see more application of machine
learning and
ai technologies on all the data to make
this insights available for all in an
accessible manner
and
in this next finding there is almost
unanimous consensus that
from our server responded that all log
data is important
for itc outcomes as well as
vast majority of our respondents said
that log data is also essential for
business outcomes and about 70 state
that it's critical and very very
important
and
the larger the organization
the
that that has more log data to manage
they're seeing they're seeing i team
uh the they're seeing that it outcomes
is even more important um
in those larger organizations with lots
of data to manage and one of the reason
is that
when an organization thinks that that
they will get useful information
for critical insights from log data then
they will
work to
harness uh that information uh from log
data and they have uh volumes of log
data so still very very interesting uh
finding
and there's also universal agreement
across all that overall in the coming
years we'll see that
data that log data volumes will just
keep continuing to grow
so what are some of the data sources
that are driving that growth
within top three data sources are
infrastructure
security and cloud services logs and
that's very closely followed by
application development containers
environments
and as a standalone sources
we're seeing content delivery network
accounts for
22 percent of um
growth of log data that people selected
as a major source
um
such as cloudflare and i find that's
really really uh interesting so tell
what what do you think about uh content
delivery networks um as a major source
for log data harvesting
yeah i think one of the things that
we've seen is that you know i think you
highlighted the places that
people tend to use log log management
heavily for infrastructure security and
cloud services um those are seen as
certain as more critical logs and i
think as we
look at part of the the volume explosion
it seems like um
teams have to make decisions about which
which logs are the most valuable so i
think cdns are kind of lower on the
percentage spectrum primarily because
they they tend to be the one of the
first ones to get tossed to the side so
i think we we've actually seen a lot of
interest um you know especially with
services like cloudflare where you can
actually get
use their log push service to receive
those cdn logs i think as we as we see
more affordable and more efficient ways
to manage logs at scale i think we're
starting to see cdns as one of those
easy wins for some of these teams to be
able to get back um insights um into
what's coming into their network and i
think in particular as we start to look
at the rise of um
you know the importance of cyber
security we're seeing cdn as kind of a
of a leading edge for
being able to assess assess threats
you know look for unwanted behavior
before it comes into the applications so
i think you know while it may be a lower
percentage on this graph i think it's a
place where we see a lot of a lot of
room for growth in the future
thank you very much uh todd
now moving on to the next question and
the set of finding is that
i.t executives and enterprise architects
report the most types of block data
growth when compared to devops series
and operational operations professional
and one thing it could be that because
of their position in the organization
but also
interestingly is that if you look at
security data
growth here there is a discrepancy
between executives and the rest of the
roles we polled so as executives
consider that security
um
source as a source for data growth is
going to be for 78 while the rest is
kind of at least
like almost 10 10 percentages lower and
it could be that it executives also need
to keep a close track of that
data growth so they can manage and then
security is seen as a big source for
data growth uh for them so it's
interesting finding when you analyze
different uh the vinylis differences in
responses between different roles
now when it comes to how much log data
is expected to grow
there is not a consensus whether it's
going to be 25 and everybody said that
but also there is something that is
going to be two to five times um growth
for instance twenty percent of people
something that there's fifty percent of
uh growth but still
the overall trend is that data will
continue to grow and as you compound
that
that information across several five
years this is just in 2022 we are seeing
kind of skyrocketing trend in overall um
growth of this data source data type
so
even as log data is growing it seems
that not everyone is happy about that
growth and in fact majorities see that
while it is very necessary for global
data to grow they have a very mixed
feelings about
this growth because log data is seen as
kind of massive incoming variety of
former so uh it's not easy uh to reap
the the or glean insights uh for massive
amount of data at least not with
existing uh methods
so
before i dive into the next group of
research findings i thought what do you
think about this kind of set of findings
um that they're summarizing the in the
first part
so i think i think that the thing that's
most interesting is that there's there's
basically a
you know everybody assumes that that
these data volumes are going to keep
growing um we're seeing come from a lot
of different places and i think the
really the only question is you know
depending on
uh each each individual respondents sort
of perspective like do they think it's
going to grow you know uh like a medium
amount or a huge amount um and so i
think you know really we're just seeing
i think we're seeing kind of the
the result of a lot of you know pushes
towards uh
moving things to the cloud uh scaling up
infrastructure i mean i think a lot of
this even started with kind of the rise
of containers you know five to seven
years ago we're just seeing a lot more
a lot more systems a lot more micro
services and a lot more infrastructure
um and as a result you know monitoring
these systems keeping them healthy i
think it's just it's starting to show us
that um the data volume required to
really manage these systems well um it's
gonna be pretty massive and i think um
you know with the the pie chart you
showed about
uh people's feelings about the log
growth um i think we're starting to
really see that practitioners are
struggling to figure out how to make use
of all this data that they're generating
um so i think it's i think it's going to
be a continued challenge as these
volumes just continue to grow year over
year if
if the tooling doesn't change
uh thank you that seems like a perfect
segue into our next um set of findings
and then as richard highlighted it's
kind of a perfect storm
of changes in the application
architectures and more massive adoption
of clouds so um so let's see how it
practitioners and it executives deal
with
all that data growth so 76
of uh survey
responses found that um enterprises do
take steps to minimize the overall log
data
volume and log data growth and the
biggest uh one is that they just store
the crit the first group is 62 said they
just store the only critical data
and some of them decide to quickly erase
data within 24 hours
and what's really amazing to me to is to
see that almost
20 percent 18 of iit teams we pulled
choose to disable logging which could be
quite dangerous right you know incidents
may happen right at that time and you
you're choosing essentially to fly uh
blind another answer which
uh we found is an undocumented anecdotal
but frequent response is that
um
enterprises do erase at some point but
they keep log data for a longer times as
the log data is needed for
compliance for audits uh and for
forensics analysis so delete log data
but uh after after it's um useful then
is still you know needed for for
troubleshooting and all these analyses
that they just mentioned
and um it's also interesting that ik
executives are
uh far less likely to report all the
efforts to minimize log data volumes and
one thing it could be either like those
efforts really don't uh reach
them or it's um it's something that
they're they're not reporting on but
it's something that essentially one
needs to
keep tabs on because um of all the
proliferation also incurs uh rising uh
costs so and then when it comes to those
costs almost 80 percent states that they
are trying to minimize costs because
there's various methods that they're
trying to minimize costs one can use
like a offline storage method like s3 or
one approach is that to try to reduce
licensing at least costs for commercial
vendors is to use open source tools and
some of the danger is that like there's
still
costs associated but they just may not
be tracked in a more traditional way
there's still infrastructure costs that
need to be taken into
advantage but it's interesting to see
that there's a huge group of people
about 40 percent that chooses to route
data to less expensive at all so there's
a lot of effort invested into
figuring out
costs and not just simply managing
volumes
and
there are also mixed results
when it comes to the success of these
efforts so
some of the survey responders said that
they wish they had data they erased
or it's very difficult to access data
once you store it to some offline method
like a cold storage
and only
12 percent think that all these efforts
uh they're they're making to reduce the
the volumes and costs are effective
um what do you think thought about this
kind of success of existing efforts or
moving data to um things such as s3 for
instance
yeah i mean i think the the use of of s3
or gcs just you know object storage in
general is it's interesting i mean it i
think it kind of indicates that
those logs have some value and while
there may be some artificial limits for
storing in the in primary log management
systems whether it's you know uh a cost
or just hardware limits they they can't
store it all in the systems that they
they want to um they don't want to get
rid of them they don't want to lose them
forever so they sort of put them in
uh
a holding place you know it's it's sort
of like um
basically like a a data lake like a low
quality data lake you can just send
archives archives of logs there um but
you know it means that there's probably
a desire for those logs to be useful at
some point in the future but the the
really the tr the trouble comes in when
you're trying to balance uh the growing
data volumes we were talking about
earlier with the the kind of fixed costs
of um existing systems and those those
costs generally aren't going down but
the data volumes are going up so at a
certain point um you kind of hit that
decision point where you have to figure
out what to do um and i think again it
just it comes back to kind of what we
were saying at the beginning of this
section which is it feels like there's a
need for
new tools that can kind of change that
cost
value paradigm a bit because we're we're
seeing that folks are trying a bunch of
strategies to reduce costs um but
ultimately it feels like they're they're
having to take a path that really
minimizes the value that they can get
from logs because things become
considerably less surgical when they're
just you know a static archive
left on object storage
yeah lots of uh lots more lots of
fascinating uh findings here um which
brings us to the next next set of
questions next question is
we wanted to understand
um what are some of the challenges in
dealing uh with log data and
our survey respondents identify all
those challenges and they chosen what
are some of the steps they find really
hard to do
and it turns out that
preparing filtering and cleaning data
seen as sort of hardest step which is
also storing data followed by the
restoring data in the cost efficient
way
and also another
another
response that we captured that is not um
in in this chart is that
uh people find the event uh correlation
not easy which also underlines uh the
fact that you just cannot dump data to
things such as s3 but you have to have
the data accessible
and easy to consume and correlate and
then figure out uh insights and queries
that we need to run on those
on those
data
and then moving to the next one 97
percent of i.t practitioners report that
existing tools um have challenges in
particular because they're not built to
handle this huge massive amount of log
data
and um there are variety of things that
those challenges are the first one is it
just takes too much time to
analyze data that are coming from a
variety of different tools like
traditional tool proliferation is still
not sold
um
then you know you see the the the
resources
that are dedicated to manage all these
tools the larger organization the more
resources they need to manage these
tools
and then some of the also very um
answers that are captured is that
different departments have different
needs and want different tools so when
that's the case how do you see the
complete picture across all the
departments and there's no um there's
lack of logging standards
which also makes ingestion pretty hard
which goes in alignment with the point
what we just made earlier that preparing
filtering and making data easy for
injection is is not nothing easy and
also another one is there's no central
place to
capture all the all those data so
there's lots of um challenges um also
scaling a price with the scaling of data
volumes is also seen as another
challenge
and um
this is where kind of scalability of
tools comes into pictures so that
we we ask teams to evaluate the risks
they face when
you
you grow your data volumes
but your tools may not scale with the
amount of data that's coming as you as
todd mentioned earlier uh from this kind
of adoption of different application
architectures like all
different like sources of data that you
need to handle that you didn't think
about which also can have
impacts such as
one obvious one is troubleshooting but a
troubleshooting and kind of long time it
takes for instance to resolve because
you need to deal with
all these data sources so
troubleshooting takes longer
but also
one interesting
response that we got is that
insecurity risks are larger and people
complain that they can expose and
accidentally log
per pii data as well as credentials
which which kind of brings again into
the mix that especially for security
scaling all the data and making sure the
tool supports the massive data growth is
essential because your security risks
are going to be higher if you don't
think about um
the massive data growth so the other are
the other risks are
applications become less reliable
you may lose some monitoring data and
then ultimately all that could lead to
loss of customers and
direct revenue impacts
and when it comes to executives um
it's also interesting that uh executives
it executives are more aware
than you would potentially expect of
resolution times
and
loss of revenue impact
when compared to the operations um or
i.t practitioners and it's very always
interesting to see what is those
discrepancy between uh different roles
and
you know it's in the second one
incidents take a longer time to resolve
that seems to be a top of mind
uh for executives because that
ultimately
impacts uh customers
um and then i'll turn to todd to share
our fir our third group of uh findings
here
um so i think really just looking at um
the
i think basically what we're seeing here
and i'm trying to think about how to
recap everything we've already said is
that you know we see that the
amount of data
that people are handling that are gonna
have to manage going forward is gonna
grow
the costs are rising and we're seeing a
lot of the the tooling choices that i
think folks have made um are directly
impacting
uh how much they're spending just
managing these log volumes and so
essentially
um what i think we're we're proposing i
think what we're advocating for here is
that we
we see that there's a necessary change
that's coming in the log management
space that i think is gonna need to
happen in order for these log volumes to
be able to be handled um with the you
know we at one end we were talking about
10 to 50
uh year-over-year growth um and as high
as you know 5x year-over-year growth um
and so i think in order for companies to
be able to really get value out of the
logs that they're creating the logs that
we've you know kind of already
articulated
we know there's value in them
the the tooling really needs to evolve
to get to a point where not only are the
costs manageable but are the
insights that people want to get out of
those logs manageable to make it you
know worth worth collecting and keeping
that data um so that you know the entire
business can get used out of it
and i think stella one thing you were
you were saying on the the slide about
the
the awareness you know it's it's not
it's not too surprising to me that you
see the the i.t executives are the ones
that are like most concerned about
revenue loss of revenue they're most
concerned about mttr and whether it's
you know reality that it takes a long
time to them i think when they're
looking at business impacts it feels
like a long time and so i think the more
uh the harder it gets as the data
volumes grow to get insights the more
value there's gonna be further and
further up the business to have tooling
that really gets you to
um you know ingesting the data volumes
that that need to be ingested and
getting insights um regardless of how
that continues to scale year over year
and then i think the the other thing
that um
is really interesting is that you know
observability has been around i mean as
a term let's say
less than a decade maybe seven seven
years or so um i think the thing that
we're seeing is that there's still a lot
of folks that
are
early in their in their observability
journey so i think looking at this slide
you know only 11 percent feel like they
have
a mature observability implementation i
think
you know it really just says that there
are a lot of tools out there but there
are still a lot of people who are
evaluating um
and adopting tools but really figuring
out how that works into a full
full-blown organization-wide strategy
and so i think if you look at the folks
that are
you know to the right on this graph that
have either uh never really embraced
observability or heard of it or you know
just haven't picked any tooling yet um
there's still a pretty big subset of
folks out there who are early in that
journey i think are really trying to
figure out what this means for their
business at large and so i think what
we'll see is as these as these folks
continue to move to the left you know
there's going to be a lot more
opportunities to bring new companies
into the observability space but i think
also we're going to just continue to see
those folks who are new to the journey
be surprised by the amount of data that
they're generating whether it's you know
logs metrics or traces
and so i think it's you know while it
feels like a relatively
widespread concept i think this data is
telling us that there's still a lot
a lot yet to
to go before we reach maturity in the
observability space
and i did similar survey
last year and
it's very interesting even though it's
still early
that compared to 2021
we see the overall growth of
observability data adoption is really
staggering 180 percent so
it's it's growing um but
we still have uh room to grow our
observability
and uh todd uh moving on to a little bit
kind of if you can walk us through some
of the next findings on the kind of the
types of data and what are the
different um
varieties and
et cetera yeah definitely and i think
the
you know as we as we talk about
observability we think about kind of
there are three you know traditional
pillars logs metrics and and traces um
and so
you know logs have probably been around
for the longest or the most ubiquitous
like they were they were kind of the
original form of getting data out of out
of these systems um and so it's kind of
not surprising that uh logs are the most
data but also you know as data volumes
continue to grow logging is really the
easiest um
easiest to add easiest for application
developers and i think the other thing
to keep in mind is that the way that
most of these metrics are generated logs
are generally generated you know um per
request you know like the the more users
interact with systems the more logs are
generated you know in in direct
correlation and there are logs from
other things as well
but i think metrics generally tend to
have a relatively
uh stable output cadence so if you look
at you know kind of prometheus standard
it's you know data gets reported once
every 10 seconds or every 30 seconds
depending on how you have it configured
so those generally are decoupled from
you know growing user volumes um so i
think we'll we'll continue to see
log data be be the driver i think in
terms of of most data and also if we're
looking at it
in terms of just you know um
you know gigabytes of of whichever data
format um logs also continue to get
uh more and more verbose we can keep
adding more tags and more fields and
more descriptive
modifiers and i think logs see that a
lot more than i think the other other
data formats um you know and then coming
back to
the data variety you know we mentioned
earlier like it can be
um
cloud cloud native deployments it can be
kubernetes infrastructure it can be cdn
it can be application logs there are all
these different places where logs come
from
and i think sort of by
almost by design you know logs have that
flexibility to really be able to just be
inserted anywhere
metrics continue to be relatively well
structured and the places that metrics
are exposed or are also well structured
so i think we're gonna we'll just see
you know logs come from a wide variety
of sources contain a wide variety of of
information within them and you know
continue to be
you know for better or worse less less
structured than the other other types of
metrics um and then when it comes down
to cost you know i think these other two
uh
you know
drivers really lead to cost having more
data having more variety you know
obviously the higher data volumes is
just expensive because it's more data um
but i think logs because they are so
they have so much variety they're harder
to index on they're harder to scale
they're harder to get
value out of the queries end up being
more complex
and so i think kind of all all three of
these these pieces here really feed in
together to just say you know logs are a
place where i think companies
are going to continue to invest heavily
i think they're going to continue to
expect
that there's a lot of rich data in those
logs
and i don't see that trend changing
anytime soon if anything i think in some
of these we might see um
logs continue to grow more potentially
that that's uh that's something that
on this graph also
is that
you know
the cost related to
managing
tracing is also very interesting
um just by the sheer amount of traces it
could be billions of traces recorded so
it seems also that
sampling needs to further grow to get
you know get the calls down because it's
it's a it's this proportional amount of
costs that's associated with tracing as
well compared to the other methods it's
kind of very fascinating definitely i
think that's a great observation
um
without moving to the
wide variety of tools to manage and
yeah i think we you know we talked a
little bit about some of these the
offline cold storage options um
and i i think those make sense you know
i mean in terms of um
you know cost per unit of storage it's
it's hard to get much cheaper than
um than s3 you know for the especially
for the durability that you get um but i
think what we're seeing here is that
as
these data volumes grow that we're
talking about you know we see companies
that have been traditionally heavy users
of tools like splunk um start to look
for more affordable options for for some
of these bigger data volumes potentially
data that's less mission critical
and so we see the adoption of open
source tools i think elasticsearch is
very common in this space
and we see
the
you know kind of that stratification of
costs and we see it sort of get pushed
down to lower tiers but the thing that i
think uh companies are starting to
realize also is that even as as those
tools are embraced and start to grow now
someone has to maintain those and
someone has to manage a new piece of
infrastructure which has its own cost it
has its own operational overhead so
there's sort of the you know cloud-based
blog management products that are that
are in the mix and there obviously are a
bunch of folks out there
and i think what we're seeing also is
that those costs have continued to grow
because as as these um you know largely
sas players i think in the log
management space see their their data
volumes grow
you know that cost gets passed on to
customers and so i think whether it's
you know using traditional log
management products or kind of doing in
a diy manner hosting your own elastic
search
uh cluster or pushing those costs to the
cloud i think what we're seeing is that
it's becoming a big expense and i think
with the data volumes that i think a lot
of companies are starting to approach
now it's becoming
i think very difficult to to fit into
the traditional i think budgets that i
think people have have planned for for
observability and so i think really what
we're
what we're you know looking at i think
is the big sea change that's coming is
finding a way to straddle some of those
traditional costs whether it's you know
on-prem or in the cloud um
versus the
the the low cost of object storage and
finding a middle ground where you can
leverage some of those cost savings but
still get the
you know the queryability and data
insights that you want from that log
data
while while finding ways to over time
kind of bring those costs down um i
think this this slide also is
interesting um just kind of looking at
how many um
how many companies actually have
uh a team that can manage some of these
these tools and so you know thirty
percent thirty seven percent say that
they don't have any dedicated resources
so it almost is a given that they're
going to have to use a cloud service or
something that that's managed by another
vendor um but twenty percent have a
dedicated team like a full team to
manage their log tooling um and so you
know whether it's that 19 or the other
44 that say they have some some
individuals that are responsible you
know there's a significant investment
there because generally these are going
to be
you know technical employees they're
going to be you know relatively
uh advanced with the the ability to
manage these tools
you know there's a significant cost
there that goes above and beyond any
software licenses or any hardware that
you're having to pay for to manage these
platforms
and my guess is that if we took data
took the same data from a year ago these
numbers would have expanded that we
would see
more dedicated teams more dedicated
individuals spending their time on this
and i think really just uh you know
whether it's logs metrics or traces i
think a lot it's the values is
increasing to companies uh but also so
is the investment um in keeping these
systems running and you know the
i don't know unsurprising part of it is
the more these are used the more they
become
part of the critical path for
uptime incident resolution and so it's
it's not acceptable for those systems to
to be down or to fail so having those
folks in charge of keeping those systems
up and running you know it becomes a
critical business function um and i
think this is just showing us that uh
the bigger the company the more data the
more likely they are to have um a
dedicated team you know or a dedicated
set of individuals that are managing
this and this comes back to i think kind
of we were saying about um
you know
business outages and loss of revenue i
think as
these systems become more more critical
more complex uh and more a focus of you
know how um
really how outages affect the business
you know we see more and more
resources from a human capital
perspective and also from uh you know
just infrastructure and
hardware expenditure on on managing this
data and getting value out of it so um
yeah i think with all the things that
kind of led up to this this slide uh
isn't super surprising to me um it
probably isn't to most people
and then i think one other thing that
we've been um starting to see a little
bit and i guess this feeds feeds a bit
into
sort of the overall narrative here about
um growth of observability data um how
this gets managed in larger companies um
by looking at you know stream processing
or or streaming observability data um
we're we're starting to see some of the
early phases of this um and i think this
this is kind of
lagging the overall observability market
a bit because it's
it's becoming
um
more important more valuable i think as
these uh data volumes have been growing
and so i think probably going back a bit
a lot of the uh
a lot of existing observability pipeline
work is probably built around something
like kafka or
rabbitmq or some of the other kind of
existing open source just general
general purpose message cues
but i think what we're starting to see
is that other solutions are emerging
that
give you the ability to have something
that's more specifically focused on
observability data and primarily
recognizing that that data is it's time
series data
there are certain things you want to be
able to do with logs or with metrics
whether it's from
you know the systems that you support
and route data to and from the ways that
you want to
you know clean that data up the way that
you want to be able to potentially look
for redact pii
i think a lot of that data becomes very
specific in the way that it needs to be
handled and so i think this is really
showing you kind of can see almost like
two two cohorts in here and the first is
folks that have some sort of uh
of a tool or in the process of picking a
tool um and my guess is that most of the
folks that say they have a fully
deployed solution are probably running
kafka or something like it under the
hood there's some newer vendors in this
space that we see some adoption for but
then you know you do see almost a
quarter of respondents are evaluating
options and then another 14 are
considering evaluating options so there
there's sort of becoming this set of
problems that i think observability
pipelines are
made to handle
that are becoming more important to to
companies and i think a lot of this kind
of the subtext i think is that a lot of
this comes back to the things we talked
about previously which are
managing the complexity of data managing
the cost of the data figuring out how to
optimize your
um you know infrastructure resources to
get the most value out of this data and
so i think it's it's still very early um
but i think observability pipelines are
going to be a thing that make
more and more appearances in the overall
observability space and start to become
that connective tissue between all these
different tools that i think people are
using
um
and then again this this kind of breaks
down you know by role whether we're
looking at i.t executives architects or
devops
where
the observability pipeline kind of
investment fits in
unsurprisingly you know the architect
role is is largely i think pushing this
as they're starting to think about
you know all the different tools all the
different observability tools they may
be using all the different data sources
um where the data is coming from and how
they think about um you know across a
large organization how do they manage
that data how are they thinking about
the growth of that data and what they're
going to need to have in place to make
that something that's scalable down the
road
and then you know i think this one's
super fun
everybody thinks there's value in uh
innovating for in observability and you
know whether it's in the
the what the tools are capable of or the
type of data that can be supported
um you know i think
it's it's recognized i think pretty
broadly now that observability is is
potentially a huge
um could bring huge value to
organizations
and i think you know as as the the
proliferation of tools continues uh as
the data volumes continue
uh i think it's becoming clear that
there's no
there's no perfect solution out there
there's no
there's really no single tool that i
think does everything that teams want um
and so i think really uh what we'll
continue to see over i think the next
next few years is that we'll see
probably
more folks move towards and stella i
know this is your one of your favorite
terms the single pane of glass like i
think there there's a desire for more
teams to be able to see more sort of
cohesive views into this data and it's
not it's not a super easy thing to do
because i think we're you know
especially when we're talking about
data in you know the petabyte scale
there's a lot there there's a lot going
on a lot of different sources on a lot
of different stakeholders um but i think
we'll you know we'll continue to see
more and more um i think interesting
innovations in not only just how we
store this data at scale
but also how we um
just how we get value out of those tools
and how we start to pass that value
further further up the chain within
these organizations so that more more
people higher up can can get value out
of the the insights that they're
gathering from observability data
um and then
yeah um i think this goes back to
another slide earlier that you had
stella but i think
having um having tools that i think do a
good job of supporting this
observability data growth um
gets people more excited about what's
possible i think a lot of what's
happening
um for the teams that are not interested
is
um it becomes so much about managing the
infrastructure managing the costs and
the pain associated it becomes almost
this
constant constant stress that you're
trying to manage these things that you
that are growing out of control and you
can't actually get to a point where you
can sit back and enjoy having having
really good tools in front of you and so
i think really this is just showing us
the more mature the observability
infrastructure is at an organization the
the more exciting i think the insights
are the more value they get from the
data and the more um
the more i think the organization feels
like more data is better and i think
that's that's what we've we've all
wanted to believe um but i think we've
been all we've been hindered a bit by by
tooling in the observability space and
um yeah i think this is just some uh
some hope hopefully for those of you out
there that have been struggling that um
modernizing your observability
infrastructure can can be a good thing
can be achieved
now moving on to more of a summary of
our discussions um
we
you know there's some there's lots of
excitement out there and to underline
though still innovation is urgently
needed
how do you see these percentages it's
very high percentages that are reporting
um some of the kind of big statements
here
yeah definitely i think i think this
this fits into a bunch of the things
we're already saying but you know um
you know just sticking your log data in
s3 you know you've achieved the goal of
storing it but you haven't achieved the
goal of getting any business value out
of it and so i think really it's it's um
you know maybe the last slide was the
perfect one to kind of fit into this so
you know 100 of people think that the
um
uh yeah sorry the previous yeah 100 of
people think that there's um you know
value in innovating in observability you
know it's not surprising that that we
see these these high percentages so yeah
we need to be able to find new ways of
storing this data at scale that are that
are queryable that are actionable um we
want to be able to make the tools
um
actually solve the problem rather than
just becoming a pain point for uh for
engineering teams and you know sometimes
you just
take the problem and you just push it on
the you know kind of those dedicated
teams we were talking about before
um and then yeah and i think you know
innovation i think is going to be key
here uh moving away from some
traditional
traditional tools and i'll i'll throw
i'll throw elasticsearch out here you
know it's it's been around for quite a
while it's it's a relatively mature tool
um it gets used a lot in log management
use cases but the
the kind of my my summary of it is that
it's it wasn't built for that it happens
to be a good fit for some of those use
cases
but ultimately it tends to become
uh more and more painful and more and
more expensive as the data volumes grow
and so i think we're seeing a lot of
that right now
starting to play out in the market and
so
um yeah it's it's comforting to me to
see that everybody seems to agree that
there's some innovation needed and that
um
i think
there there is a possibility to i think
do better with observability um through
a lot of the i think the new products
that are starting to come to market
now that we covered quite a lot of
research
um
we gleaned some new insights some
expected some unexpected thought could
you share with us a little bit about
what are some of the recommendations we
can have for people out there
in the space
yeah so i think um some of these are
going to be
relatively straightforward but i think
you know as you start to look at your at
your options at your at your existing
choices for observability um
there are you know products that are
becoming available that are
you know leveraging
cloud native um architectures that are
you know sitting on top of things like
s3 or gcs um that are are finding a
better way to
um sort of dynamically stratify these
these log layers um that i think people
are starting are trying to figure out
themselves so i think really you know
keep an eye out for for tools i think
help with that cost management
i think we'll start to see a lot more of
those out there in the market
and i think right now a lot of the tools
that folks are using
i would say are relatively
um
i guess we're sitting on the kind of a
previous generation of of uh technology
and so i think a lot of the costs that
are out there in the market right now
are artificially high um you know i
think and along with that um
i think there's there's a desire to keep
especially with logs not so much with
metrics um a desire to keep data around
for longer periods of time so i think um
you know as we see desires grow to have
um
you know audit and compliance ready
storage for logging
there's also the ability to be able to
go back and run
uh potentially you know machine learning
models on historical log data to get
customer insights um you know i think
starting to factor those those uh
storage terms into your plans and then
figure out how you can how you can
leverage your tools to be able to to
make that storage work in a cost
effective way is going to be important
um
finding ways to expose some of this
observability data to other parts of
your organization i think largely it's
been
mostly restricted to devops and sre but
i think as we start to see
you know more of these mature
type of observability infrastructures we
discussed i think
a big part of that is starting to
surface that data surface those insights
surface the
you know the mttrs the the incident
responses to other stakeholders is
important um
you know i think paired up with the the
low cost
um
and and long-term storage just finding
finding tools that give you the power to
get uh
extract data from your from your
historical archives whether it's being
able to have it online and queryable or
it's uh you know being able to have a
set of of tools that can
quickly look over some of that cold data
without having to
you know delegate individual engineers
to go pull that data down and and and
look through it um i think there are a
bunch of different ways to go about
about getting there
um and then i think kind of on to the
innovations in observability pipelines
and observability data management
looking for tools that can help you with
some pre-processing some you know
overall reduction of data volumes
um i think i think that's going to be
something as i said that is
is growing a lot and gets a lot of
innovation
going forward and we'll start to see
that appear in a lot more organizations
um
and then
yeah just integrating with with other
existing tools and so i think a lot of
this is
as you look at potentially observability
pipelines you know you don't necessarily
have to replace your tools
i think especially if you look at some
of these tools that are deeply embedded
in
you know security organizations or have
have business critical insights
you don't need to replace them
you can find tools that can be operated
alongside them and you can use
observability pipelines and things like
that to figure out which data goes into
which tool and how do you
kind of shuffle that that data in an
automated way and make it possible to
you know essentially let the tools
rebalance that data for you so that you
can um you know more effectively
optimize the costs of the tools that
you're choosing to put data into
and let the
the use cases or the needs from that
data drive um you know which which tool
and which cost profile is associated
with that data so they kind of you know
all these things together i think are
things that we'll start to see uh more
and more as these log volumes continue
to grow um but i think the upside is
that there are
there are ways and tools and strategies
i think to get to a a manageable um
profile and i think again going back to
one of the earlier slides the more
mature organizations that have gotten to
a place where they figured these things
out
they do actually start to get value out
of that observability data and get
excited about having more of it
available but i think a lot of it comes
down to
picking the right tools and strategies
to
to make sure that your organization can
be successful
thank you very much todd now moving into
the
the q a portion
of our presentation uh we covered quite
a lot of insights and if you'd like to
get
the full
report um here's the link uh you can
download it for free and read um the
details and keep it for you and kind of
see if you if you find this uh summaries
this report
something that you've seen in real
in practice so
uh over to richard to see if there are
any questions on the line
yep we do have a few questions
the first question is
based on findings what do you see for
observability going beyond 2022.
this is for dodd
yeah happy happy to answer that one um
yeah so i i mean i think we we talked
about it in a bunch of different ways
but i i think the biggest piece of it is
that you know observability is
here to stay
um i think
we're just going to continue to see data
volumes grow
i think jumping into a parallel space
you know um
iot data is another it's another you
know time series use case that's similar
to observability um
you know that that's also been
continuing to grow and largely fueled by
uh the number of devices that are out
there the number of um
data points that you want to be able to
get insight on and i think what we're
really seeing is is a lot of these
parallel evolutions where
um you know the compute resources are
becoming more ubiquitous the number of
um whether it's
microservices or containers or
individual processes that are being
monitored
you know we're seeing that hardware
become
hardware and sort of the the low-level
software becoming commoditized to a
point where it's just become a utility
and i think the the growth of
observability data is really
kind of just the tail end of that of
that growth and now everyone expects
there to be
logs and metrics and charts and graphs
and insights into all of this stuff and
i think that's just going to continue to
grow
probably not you know i think we had
some of the initial some of the
respondents that you know thought that
their organizations might see you know
5x growth
or more um but i think my guess is that
a lot of those a lot of those companies
are seeing that growth because they're
um in the middle of their
um you know kind of cloud migration
journey or embracing tools like
kubernetes and they're starting to see
that but i think
the the industry as a whole i think
we'll see pretty healthy year-over-year
growth for quite a while um yeah and i
think just going back to the things we
said before it's going to come down to
tooling choices to i think really get
value as that stuff grows um
yeah i think there's there's going to be
a lot of
a lot of cost explosions and a lot of
pain for some of these teams that are
managing these tools but i think we're i
think we're in a place now we're
starting to see the rise of a of a new
set of tools that will will make these
challenges easier
do we have more questions richard or
we do thank you todd the next question
is were there any surprise findings in
this year's survey
i guess we could go to stella
um yes um i spent last 10 years in
you know monitoring observability log
management space um some of the some of
the responses are quite
expected such as you know
troubleshooting times take longer or
proliferation of tools but some of the
findings such as if you don't
scale with the your tool doesn't scale
with the growth of data
that you will be exposing um yourself to
pii risks or accidentally exposing
credentials
um and some of the kind of the the
the more urgent need we have in security
space to to take care to take
you know harness all the data is very
very interesting um to see um especially
as the amount of data
volume grows that kind of
keeping tabs on incidents and potential
risk and security is becoming
more urgent than ever um in this space
so that's something that was very
surprising for me uh because this
surgery specifically targeted rt
organizations and those survey um the
security
uh realm is kind of shining through even
for for even though we didn't pull
directly security professionals so
that's very very interesting finding for
me
all right we have another question here
does era software offer a self-managed
deployment
yeah great question and uh we didn't we
didn't talk too much about the specific
product offerings but yeah i think um
our our era search product is is
definitely deployable on prem
um
or or in a you know a self-managed cloud
um
i think it's it's been it's something i
think is somewhat unique to log
management versus metrics and traces
because i think to stella's point uh
just a minute ago
um logs tend to have a lot of risk for
having pii and so i think for a lot of
our customers being able to take our
product and run it in their own
infrastructure whether it's cloud or
actually like physical hardware um is a
relatively big selling point and i think
there are a lot of um other
sas vendors that you know they're sas
only and so it becomes very difficult to
actually have full control over that
infrastructure so um i think given given
the potential for
you know security breaches and things
like that i think being able to go um
on-prem for for log management is
actually really important i think is
going to be a kind of a key part of our
business going forward um and i think it
also just gives it gives those customers
the ability to
um run the software they want and
control how they manage costs and
whether they want to
you know move to uh you know a different
hosting provider or
negotiate discounts on hardware um you
know they're free to do that and the you
know the price of the software can be a
bit decoupled from the actual hardware
that's being run on it
right thank you and then this question
can go to you as well todd what are your
expectations for streaming pipelines
adoption
yeah awesome um i i get pretty excited
about this because i see that we've had
um
you know there there are lots of logs
coming from lots of different places i
think going to some of the the charts we
highlighted earlier um and i think you
know we've seen a bit of um
my new favorite term agent sprawl uh
kind of in recent years and it becomes
very hard to get
the the right logs from the right places
in the right format
deal with back pressure deal with
failures and you know especially as
we've got um you know
really infrastructure running all these
different clouds all these different
places you know downtime happens all the
time and so i think finding a way to
remove the reliance on on agents to be
responsible for
um you know really data data cleansing
data formatting data transformation um
and pushing that to a more centralized
place
you know whether it's you know just
uh
a
very generic message cue something like
that or more
you know
a
specific type of observability pipeline
i think we're going to see
that
that's going to become more common and
it's going to fit better with the
the tooling and trends that i think
modern development teams are starting to
embrace whether it's
you know get up style workflows uh being
able to push configuration changes
um
more you know more dynamically um
whereas i think rolling out
configuration changes to thousands of
agents across your entire infrastructure
is actually pretty pretty difficult to
do pretty difficult to coordinate um and
i think that that
evolution of the observability pipelines
and the broader kind of observability
data management concept i think we're
going to see become something that more
more organizations and more teams are
going to become reliant on and it's
actually going to start to be a pretty
big part of how
those orgs manage
these huge data volumes across lots of
different tools and have the have the
confidence that things are working the
way that they want
and that they can
continue to make dynamic changes as you
know as new products ship as the company
changes as as teams grow and as volume
scale
so yeah i think we'll start to see i
think it's it's still really early in
that space i think we'll start to see a
lot more of that over the next uh year
or two for sure
we're coming to almost four hours so if
there are more questions please reach
out to us directly
and
with that i turn to
richard to say through your closing
words
yep thank you thank you todd vicky
stella thanks everyone for participating
in today's session keep an eye on your
email we'll send you a recording of the
webinar if you have any questions or
want a personal demo you can reach out
to us by visiting era dot co co slash
contact and filling out the quick form
that's there you can also sign up to try
aircloud completely free by going to
era.co and clicking the free trial
button in the upper right corner and
you'll get your first terabyte of log
data for free
a big thank you from all of us here at
era for being part of this webinar we
look forward to seeing you at our next
event
thank you richard thank you thank you
thanks everybody
all right
sure